[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my marvel avengers game
review recently like a lot of you i had
a chance to play the beta so i'll try to
cover
as much of it as possible without any
big spoilers for parts of the story that
they didn't already reveal
in the trailer footage so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we are doing a
giveaway for a
copy of the game all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite big marvel game
on the video
i'm sure a lot of you are going to say
spider-man ps4 i will be referencing
spider-man ps4 the gameplay the story a
lot when talking about marvel's avengers
because it is the closest comparison in
terms of the way the game works the way
the story works
and i will be discussing all the parts
of the game marvel avengers that they
already publicly revealed in the
previous trailers
so far it does have the potential to be
a solid game it doesn't hold a candle to
spider-man ps4
yet but the game hasn't even launched
yet is still in beta so hopefully with
some patches they can tune some of the
aspects and the things that i wasn't
really happy with
but the first big gameplay that you get
into at the beginning is the san
francisco fight the tutorial mission
that they use to teach you about all the
game systems the mechanics the character
abilities the dynamics
you start with the avengers in the past
on a mission in san francisco that's the
mission you saw in all the early trailer
footage where they're fighting
taskmaster
who's working for modoc and aim they
wind up framing the avengers in a plot
to destroy the public's trust in them
is this big modoc plan involving
inhumans so taskmaster
obviously getting ready to show up in
the mcu for the first time in the black
widow movie
we would have already seen him were not
for the virus delaying all movies
so there are some story elements in the
game that make you wonder if the
developers were trying to gain some
synergy
by doing things in the story the marvel
movies were also
doing with its characters heading into
marvel phase four this will make more
sense in a second because the game was
originally supposed to come out closer
to avengers infinity war in avengers end
game just riding
all that hype the whole theme of the
game is built on the idea of avengers
disassembled
from the comics even though obviously
things are very different from the comic
book versions
without getting into big spoilers one of
the main a-list avengers winds up dying
or seemingly dying during that big san
francisco attack that turns into this
major disaster
the avengers break up quote-unquote
disassemble and then even though you get
pov from all the avengers characters
the main pov character at least at the
beginning is mostly kamala khan's miss
marvel
she's like the young up-and-coming
avengers fan girl who idolized
all the avengers and she has to try and
help the surviving avengers
reassemble to deal with this big
inhumans plot that modoc has
kevin feige recently announced that miss
marvel is getting a big avengers endgame
spin-off disney plus series we don't
know when that's going to premiere
probably sometime in 2022 because
they're casting it right now but we
don't know who's gonna be playing the
live action miss marvel yet
but after a quick time jump she and the
hulk go to start finding the other
avengers like iron man
so i will say like in terms of character
dynamics she actually does have a really
good dynamic with the hulk so maybe
we'll actually wind up seeing the hulk
show up during the miss marvel tv series
mark ruffalo already confirmed that he's
going to be showing up during the
she-hulk disney plus series
and i will mention some she-hulk stuff
because we found out about some of the
playable characters that marvel avengers
is going to be dropping with dlc
later on remember i said the game trying
to use some synergy with what marvel
phase 4 is doing with the movies and the
tv shows
i was a big fan of the comic book stuff
they were trying to riff on with
the game even though everyone had their
complaints about the way the characters
look i feel like all the actors
performances
were solid i feel like it was kind of
unrealistic to expect the game to use
the same characters
as the movies like robert downey jr
would charge
tens of millions of dollars to use his
likeness there's no way the game was
going to spend an extra 100 million
dollars to get the lightness rights for
all the characters and to get the actors
to come in to perform all the motion
capture for that stuff
it's the same situation as spider-man
ps4 none of those
characters look like the movie versions
of the characters in terms of the
overall story i feel like right now as
it is it's not quite as good as the
story of spider-man ps4 but i think part
of the reason for that
is that they're trying to juggle so many
more characters we're talking about the
avengers here
in spider-man ps4 really only had to
focus on one character spider-man
himself
with the other characters around him
being relatively minor by comparison
that's the main reason why most big
directors don't want to even do huge
avengers movies or can't do them
one of the reasons why the russos were
able to handle both avengers infinity
war and avengers end game is because
there's two of them
instead of just one of them even then a
lot of people complain that not all the
avengers characters got the scenes that
they deserve
during avengers end game there just
wasn't room for everything
there's one thing right now about the
character models in the game that people
are complaining about that spider-man
ps4 managed to nail so i'm hoping that
marvel avengers would be able to fix it
later on
but one thing it does do better than
spider-man ps4 is that it goes
way further beyond when it comes to
character customization and item
customization
they give you this level of tuning that
you can apply to characters skills and
gear stats that's great if you love
that level of customization different
gear designed for different boss fights
giving you bigger bonuses and certain
skill trees and switching back and forth
for different types of missions
and if you don't like digging that deep
into characters and you feel like it's
way too complicated through the menu
system
they do have a really simple option
built in that just gives you the best
possible loadout in settings for your
gear
but the real problem as you've probably
heard other reviewers
talking about is the fact that different
gear all the different suits the stats
the items
don't really have any effect on your
character's physical appearance
in the game so even if you gear up with
a bunch of really cool armor and weapons
on the different avengers characters
your character won't look any different
running around and it's something that
they need to change
because spider-man ps4 nailed this
aspect of the game
part of the whole fun of spider-man ps4
is trying out
all of spider-man's different suits and
then seeing him web sling around the
city
wearing them in the game i think part of
the difficulty in marvel avengers doing
this
at least at launch is the fact that they
have so many more
playable characters that they would have
to implement that feature for whereas in
spider-man ps4
you just have one character spider-man
with a ton of different looks
the actual gameplay was a little buggy
but the game is still in beta so you
kind of
expect that as of me posting this video
overall the gameplay was
fun but the minor complaint that i have
that i think a lot of other people had
was that the main characters who are
supposed to have
wildly different power levels in the
comics like the hulk
vastly more powerful than iron man miss
marvel black widow
didn't really feel like he was doing
more damage
per fight than any of the other
characters like right now as the game
has been balanced you could use
any of the characters for any of the
boss fights early on and it wouldn't
make any difference
there was a hilarious bug this past
weekend that a user found that allowed
the hulk to jump into iron man's
hulkbuster armor nice avengers infinity
war easter egg hopefully they don't
patch that out too fast
but one character that you only get a
little time to experience early on
is thor you only get a little with him
in the early mission he's a lot of fun
but like i said it's that same
interchangeable powers problem aside
from a few different abilities he
doesn't feel like he gives you an
epic advantage over playing as the hulk
or iron man maybe this is something
that'll change later in the end game
content when the characters skills
become more specialized and the boss
fights become way harder i know you all
have questions about what's going on
with spider-man in the game he was not
playable
in the beta that's only going to be
available after launch on the
playstation versions of the game
so the way they explain it is that the
spider-man story content will be
different from the main path so it'll
feel more like traditional
dlc extra missions so if you do have the
xbox version and you can't play as
spider-man you won't be missing any
critical story or
gear that would give you a big advantage
over not having spider-man
there were a lot of websites this week
that were claiming that the spider-man
that shows up in the game though won't
be
insomniac's version from spider-man ps4
so take that for what you will it sounds
like it'll be a slightly different
version of peter parker spider-man
there were a lot of people that saw that
miles morales spider-man ps5 trailer and
they're like maybe peter parker isn't
there because he's busy over in san
francisco with the avengers game
so that just kind of debunks that theory
the other characters that we actually
just found out about that they're
releasing after launch as dlc
later in the game are hawkeye then war
machine she-hulk
and then the kate bishop hawkeye there
might be more new characters after that
later on but those are the only ones
that we know about right now
many thanks to everyone that data mined
those extra characters
you only get a little bit of modok early
on he's the main villain they kind of
explained the whole inhuman subplot
during that last big trailer
modoc and aim are the big villains of
the game trying to control inhumans
which have been proliferating all over
the earth
all the robots that you see with those
wolverine looking claws are the super
adaptoid robots from the comics which
are also creations of ames
and speaking of wolverine here's another
one of the weaknesses i feel like of the
game and just a
symptom of game development in general
because it takes so long to do this
because they started developing the game
years ago way before
marvel ever got the rights to the
characters back and they were trying to
gain some synergy from avengers infinity
war avengers endgame marvel phase 4
stuff it feels like that's why they went
for inhumans in the game instead of
using
x-men because i feel like right now just
in terms of big marvel movies
most people are hyped up to see the new
mcu versions of the x-men characters
so it may have benefited the game more
had they leaned harder into x-men
but like i said when they started
developing the game the x-men characters
were still with fox so they were
probably trying to swerve on that at the
time
the developers did confirm though that
they were allowed to use x-men
characters in their game so there might
be some more x-men characters that pop
up later through dlc
it would be really badass to see
wolverine show up in the marvel avengers
game
if you don't know anything about modoc
he was actually a character that was
rumored to be in ant-man 3 in the marvel
movies but modoc is actually an acronym
that stands for mental
organism designed only for killing he
starts out as a normal person who's
turned into this
creation but then he winds up rebelling
against aim and taking over the
organization himself
eventually after the avengers wind up
capturing him they throw him in prison
he starts working for the government in
order to commute his sentence
thinking about thunderbole's easter eggs
it's always possible that they could do
something with that because we know that
they're building up to a big
thunderbolts project in the mcu
just think about all those villains that
are chilling out on the raft right now
and imagine that
is their home base in a thunderbolts
disney plus series
but if you're a big fan of the avengers
in the comics the movies or
bigger aaa marvel games like spider-man
ps4 i feel like the marvel avengers game
is fun but it still has a long ways to
go if it wants to beat
insomniac's spider-man ps4 and that
doesn't even get into spider-man ps5 or
the miles morales game which is
also coming out later this year i will
do separate videos about
that and i will give a couple copies of
the game away once they release it but
it's not coming out for a little while
longer
once you do have a chance to play marvel
avengers though let me know in the
comments what you think of the game so
far
and click here for that full spider-man
ps5 miles morales trailer and click here
for my brand new spider-man 3
marvel movie video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe i'll see you
guys tonight
you